The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GILBERT STRANG: OK.
So what I promised, and
now I'm going to do it,
to talk about gradient
descent and its descendants.
So from the basic
gradient descent formula,
which we all know--
let me just write that down--
the new point is the old point.
We're going downwards,
so with a minus
sign that's the step size.
And we compute the
gradient at XK.
So we're descending
in the direction
of the negative gradient.
And that's the basic formula,
and is in every book studied.
So my main reference for
some of these lectures
is the book by Stephen Boyd
and Lieven Vandenberghe.
And I mention again, Professor
Boyd is talking, in this room,
next week Wednesday,
Thursday and he's speaking
somewhere on Friday at 4:30--
and of course,
about optimization.
And he's a good lecturer,
yeah, very good.
OK.
So there's steepest descent,
and I've redrawn my picture
from last time.
Now I'll go over there
and look at that picture.
But let me say what's coming.
So that's pretty standard--
very standard, you could say.
Then this is the improvement
that is widely used.
Adding in something
called momentum
to avoid the zigzag that
we're going to see over there.
And there's another
way to do it.
There's a Russian
guy named Nesterov.
His papers are not easy
to read, but they've
got serious content.
And one thing he did
was find an alternative
to momentum that also
accelerated the descent.
So this produces-- these
both produce faster descent
than the ordinary one.
OK.
And then you know,
looking ahead,
that for problems
of machine learning,
they're so large
that the gradient--
we have so many variables--
all those weights are variables.
And that could-- hundreds of
thousands is not uncommon.
So then the gradient becomes
a pretty big calculation,
and we just don't have
to do it all at once.
We don't have to change--
so XK is a vector of all the
weights, or-- and using--
and our equations are
matching the training data.
So we don't have to use all
the training data at once,
and we don't.
We take a batch of
training data, like one.
But that's sort of inefficient
in the opposite direction,
to do them one at a time.
So we don't know want to
do them one at a time,
but we don't want to do
all million at a time.
So the compromise
is a mini batch.
So stochastic gradient descent
does a mini batch at a time--
a mini batch of
training, of samples
training data each step.
And it can choose
them stochastically--
meaning randomly, or
more systematically--
but we do a batch at a time.
And that will come after the--
it'll come next week after a
marathon, of course, on Monday.
OK.
So let me just go back to
that picture for a moment,
but then the real
content of today
is this one with momentum added.
OK.
I just-- I probably haven't
got the picture perfect yet.
I'm just not an artist,
but I think I'm closer.
So this is-- those
are the level sets.
Those are the sets f
of x equal constant.
And in our model problem,
f of x is x1 squared--
or let's say x squared plus
b-y squared equal constant with
small b--
b below 1 and maybe far below 1.
So those are ellipses.
Those are the equations
of an ellipse,
and that's what I tried to draw.
And if b is small,
then the ellipses
are long and thin like that.
And now, what's the picture?
You start with a point x
nought, and you descend
in the steepest direction.
So the steepest direction is
perpendicular to the level set,
right?
Perpendicular to the ellipse.
So you're down, down, down.
You're passing
through more ellipses,
more ellipses, more ellipses.
Eventually, your tangent to a--
it seems to me it
has to be tangent.
I didn't read this, but
looks reasonable to me that
the farthest in level
set-- farthest in ellipse--
you're tangent to, and then
you start going up again.
So that's the optimal point
to stop to end that step.
And then where does
the next step go?
Well, you're here.
You're on an ellipse.
That's a level set.
You want to move in
the gradient direction.
That's perpendicular
to the level set.
So you're going
down somewhere here,
and you're passing again
through more and more ellipses,
until you're tangent to
a smaller ellipse here.
And you see the zigzag pattern.
And that zigzag
pattern is what we
see, by formula, in Boyd's book,
and many other places, too.
The formula has those
powers of the magic number.
So we start at the--
start at the point b1,
and follow this path.
Then the X's are the same
b times this quantity
to the kth power.
And here is that quantity,
b minus 1 over b plus 1.
So you see, for a small b,
that's a negative number.
So it's flipping sine in the
X's, as we saw in the picture.
At least that part of
the picture is correct.
The y's don't flip sine.
So this was XK, and
when k is 0, we got b.
YK is, I think, is
not flipping sine.
So that looks good.
And then FK-- the value of f--
also was the same quantity.
FK is that same quantity
to the kth times f0.
So that quantity's
all important.
And so the purpose
of today's lecture,
is to tell you what
the momentum term--
what improvement--
what change that
brings in the basic
steepest descent formula.
I'm going to add on
another term, which
is going to have some--
give us some memory
of the previous step.
And so when I do that, I want
to track that kind of descent
for the new--
for the accelerated descent,
and track it and see
what improvement the
momentum term brings.
And so the final result
will be to tell you
the improvement in the--
produced by the momentum term.
Maybe while I have
your attention,
I'll tell you what it is now.
And then will come the
details, the algebra.
And to me-- so this
is as my own thought--
it's a miracle that
the algebra, which
is straightforward-- you really
see the value of eigenvectors.
We explained eigenvectors in
class, but here you see why--
how to use them.
That is really a good exercise.
But to me it's a miracle that
the expression with momentum
is very much like that
expression, but different,
of course.
The decay-- the term that tells
you how fast the decay is--
is smaller.
So you're taking kth power.
So let me-- I'll write that
down, if that's all right.
I didn't plan to do--
to reveal the final result at
the beginning of the lecture.
But I think you want to
see where we're going.
So with momentum-- and we
have to see what that means--
this term of 1 minus b
over 1 plus b becomes--
changes to-- 1 minus
square root of b over 1
plus square root of b.
So I mentioned that
before, but I don't think
I wrote it down as clearly.
So the miracle to me is to
get such a nice expression
for the--
because you'll see the algebra
is-- it works, but it involves
more terms because
of momentum, involves
doing a minimization
of eigenvalues,
and yet it comes out nicely.
And then you have to see
the importance of that.
So let me-- I will just
take the same example
that I mentioned before.
If b is 1 over 100, then
this is 0.99 over 1.01.
I think that these--
there's a square here, 2k.
So if we're-- so I'll just
keep the square there,
no big change, but I'm looking
at-- now here-- at the square.
Maybe squares are everywhere.
OK.
So that's close to 1.
And now let's compare
that with what we have.
So if b is 1 over 100--
so I'm taking b
to be 1 over 100--
and square root
of b is 1 over 10.
So this is 0.9 over 1.1 squared.
And there's a
tremendous-- that's
a lot smaller than that is.
Right.
9/10-- 9 over 11,
compared to 99 over 101.
This one is
definitely-- oh, sorry.
Yeah, this reduction factor
is well below that one.
So it's a good thing.
It's worth doing.
And now what does it involve?
So I'll write down the
expression for the stochastic--
here we go.
OK.
So here's one way to see it.
The new X is the old
X minus the gradient.
And now comes an extra term,
which gives us a little memory.
Well, sorry.
The algebra is slightly nicer
if I write it a little bit
differently.
I'll create a new quantity,
ZK, with a step size.
OK.
So if I took ZK to
be just the gradient,
that would be steepest descent.
Nothing has changed.
But instead, I'm
going to take ZK--
well, it's leading term
will be the gradient.
But here comes
the momentum term.
I add on a multiple beta.
One way to do it is
of the previous Z.
So the Z is the
search direction.
Z is the gradient
you're traveling.
It is the direction
you're moving.
So it's different from
that direction there.
That direction was the gradient.
This direction is the
gradient corrected by a memory
term, a momentum term.
And one way to interpret that
is to say that that ball--
is to think of a heavy ball,
instead of just a point.
I think of a heavy ball.
It, instead of bouncing back and
forth as uselessly as this one,
it tends to--
it still bounces, of course,
on the sides of the level set--
but it comes down
the valley faster.
And that's the effect of this.
So you could play with
different adjustment
terms, different corrections.
So I'll follow through this one.
Nesterov had another way to
make a change in the formula,
and there are certainly
others beyond that.
OK, so how do we
analyze that one?
Well, the real point is,
we've sort of, by taking--
by involving the
previous step, we now
have a three level method
instead of a two level method,
you could say.
This involves only
level K plus 1
and level K. The formulas
now involve K plus 1K,
and K minus 1.
It's just like going from
a first order differential
equation to a second order
differential equation.
I'm not really thinking
that K is a time variable.
But in the analogy, K
could be a time variable.
So that here we had a
first order equation.
If I wanted to model
that, it's sort
of a DXDT coming in
there, equal gradient.
And these models
are highly useful
and developed for sort
of a continuous model
of steepest descent--
a continuous motion instead
of the discrete motion.
OK.
So that would-- that
continuous model for that guy
would be a first order in time.
For this one, it'll be
second order in time.
And second order
equations, of course,
and there'd be
constant coefficients
in our model problem.
And the thing about a second
order equation that we all know
is, there is a momentum term--
a damping term, you could say--
in multiplying the
first derivative.
So that's what a second
order equation offers--
is the inclusion
of a damping term
which isn't present in
the original first order.
OK.
So how do we analyze this?
I have to-- so how do
you analyze second order
differential equations?
You write them as a system
of two first order equations.
So that's exactly what
we're going to do here,
in the discrete case.
We're going to see--
because we have two equations.
And they're first
order, and we can--
let me play with them for
a moment to make them good.
OK.
So I'm going to have--
so this will go to two
first order equations,
in which the first one--
I'm just going to
copy, XK plus 1
is XK minus that step size ZK.
Yeah.
OK.
Time the previous
times step here--
the next time step on the left.
OK.
So I just copied that.
Now this one I'm going
to increase K by 1.
So in order to have that
looking to match this,
I'll write that as ZK plus 1,
and I'll bring the K, saying,
grad FK plus 1 equal beta ZK.
That work with you?
I just, in this thing,
instead of looking at it at K,
I went to K plus 1.
And I put the K plus
1 terms on one side.
OK.
So now I have a--
let's see.
Let's remember, we're doing--
the model we're doing is F
equal a half X transpose SX.
So the gradient of F is SX.
So what I've written there,
for gradient, is really--
I know what that gradient is.
So that's really SX K plus 1.
OK.
How to analyze that.
What happens as K travels
forward 1, 2, 3, 4, 5?
We have a constant coefficient
problem at every step.
The XZ variable is getting
multiplied by a matrix.
So here's XZ at K plus 1.
And over here will
be XZ at step K.
And I just have to
figure out what matrix
is multiplying here and here.
OK.
And I guess here I see it.
For the first equation
has a 1 and a minus S,
looks like, in the first row.
And it has a beta
in the second row.
And here the first equation
has a 1, 0 in that row.
And then a minus
S. So I'll put in
minus S, multiplying
XK plus 1, and then
the 1 that multiplies ZK plus 1.
Is that all right?
Sorry.
I've got two S's, and I
didn't draw that one--
didn't write that
one in large enough,
and I'd planned to
erase it anyway.
This is the step sizes.
This is the matrix.
But it's not quite
fitting its place.
This is the point where I'm
going to use eigenvalues.
I'm going to follow
each eigenvalue.
That's the whole point.
When I follow each
eigenvalue-- each eigenvector,
I should say--
I'll follow each eigenvector
of S. So let's do that.
So eigenvectors of S-- what
are we going to call those?
Lambda, probably.
So SX equal lambda X. I
think that's what's coming.
Or Q. To do things
right, I want to remember
that S is a positive,
definite symmetric matrix.
That's why I call
it S, instead of A.
So I really should
call the eigen--
it doesn't matter,
but to be on the ball,
let me call the eigenvector
Q, and the eigenvalue lambda.
OK.
So now I want to follow
this eigenvector.
So I'm supposing that
XK is sum CK times Q.
I'm assuming that X is in the--
tracking this eigenvector.
And I'm going to assume that ZK
is some other constant times Q.
Everybody, do you see?
That's a vector and
that's a vector.
And I want scalars.
I want to attract
just scalar CK and DK.
So that's really
what I have here.
This was a little tricky,
because X here is a vector,
and two components
are N components.
I didn't want that.
I really wanted just to
track an eigenvector.
Once I've settled
on the direction Q,
everything is-- all vectors
are in the direction of Q.
So we just have numbers
C and D to track.
OK.
So I'm going to rewrite
this correctly, as, yeah.
Well, let me keep going
with this little formula.
Then what will--
I needed an SX.
What will SXK be?
If XK is in the direction of
the eigenvector Q, and it's CK--
what happens when
I multiply by S?
Q was an eigenvector.
So the multiplying
by S gives me a--
AUDIENCE: Eigenvalue.
GILBERT STRANG:
Eigenvalue, right?
So it's CK lambda Q.
Everything is a multiple of Q.
And it's only those
multiples I'm looking
for, the C's and the D's.
And then the lambda
comes into the S term.
Yeah.
I think that's probably
all I need to do this.
And then the gradient-- yeah.
So that's the
gradient, of course.
This is the gradient of F at K--
is that one.
OK.
So instead of this,
let me just write
what's happening if I'm tracking
the coefficients CK plus 1
and DK plus 1.
Then what I really meant
to have there is 1, 0.
And minus S is a minus lambda.
Is that right?
Yeah.
When I multiply the eigenvector
by S, I'm just getting--
oh, it's a lambda times a CK.
Yeah.
Lambda times the
CK-- that's good.
I think that that's the left
hand side of my equation.
And on the right hand
side, I have here.
That's 1.
And this was the
scalar, the step size.
other coefficient.
It's the beta.
So I want to choose--
what's my purpose now?
That gives me the--
what happens at every
step to the C and D.
So I want to choose the
two things that I have--
I'm free to choose
are S and beta.
So that's my big job--
choose S and beta.
OK.
Now I-- to make--
oh, let me just shape this
by multiplying the inverse
of that, and get it over here.
So that will really--
you'll see everything.
So CK plus 1, DK plus 1.
What's the inverse of 1, 0?
Oh, I don't think
I want to-- that
would have a tough time
finding an inverse.
It was a 1, wasn't it?
Yeah.
OK.
So I'm going to multiply by
the inverse of that matrix
to get it over here.
And what's the inverse
of 1, 1 minus lambda?
It's 1, 1 plus lambda.
So that the inverse
brought it over here,
times this matrix, 1, 0 beta,
and minus the step size.
That's what multiply CK DK.
So we have these
simple, beautiful steps
which come from tracking
one eigenvector--
makes the whole problem scalar.
So I multiply those two
matrices and I finally
get the matrix that I
really have to think about.
1, 0 times that'll be 1 minus
S. Lambda 1 times that'll
be a lambda there.
And minus lambda S plus beta.
Beta minus lambda
S. That's the matrix
that we see at every step.
Let me call that matrix R.
So I've done some algebra--
more than I would always do
in a lecture--
but it's really my--
I wouldn't do it if it
wasn't nice algebra.
What's the conclusion?
That conclusion is that
with the momentum term--
with this number beta available
to choose, as well as S,
the step--
the coefficient
of the eigenvector
is multiplied at every
step by that matrix R.
R is that matrix.
And of course, that matrix
involves the eigenvalue.
So we have to think about--
what do we want to do now?
We want to choose
beta and S to make
R as small as possible, right?
We want to make R as
small as possible.
And we are free to choose beta
and S, but R depends on lambda.
So I'm going to make
it as small as possible
over the whole range
of possible lambdas.
So let me-- so now
here we really go.
So we have lambda between sum.
These are the eigenvalue
of S. And what we know--
what's reasonable to
know-- is a lower bound.
It's a positive.
This is a symmetric
positive definite matrix.
A lower bound and an upper
bound, for example, m was B,
and M was 1, in
that 2 by 2 problem.
And this is what we know,
that the eigenvalues
are between m and M. And
the ratio of m to M--
well, if I write--
this is the key quantity.
And what's it called?
Lambda max divided by
lambda min is the--
AUDIENCE: Condition number.
GILBERT STRANG:
Condition number.
Right.
This is all sometimes
written kappa--
Greek letter kappa-- the
condition number of S.
And when that's big, then the
problem is going to be harder.
When that's 1, then my
matrix is just a multiple
of the identity matrix.
And the problem is trivial.
When capital M and
small m are the same,
then that's saying that
the largest and smallest
eigenvalues are identical,
that the matrix is
a multiple of the identity.
That's the condition number one.
But the bad one is when it's
1 over b, in our example,
and that could be very large.
OK.
That's where we
have our problem.
Let me just insert about the
ordinary gradient descent.
Of course, the textbooks find a
estimate for how fast that is.
And of course, it
depends on that number.
Yeah.
So it depends on that
number, and you exactly
saw how it depended
on that number.
Right.
But now we have a
different problem.
And we're going to finish it.
OK.
So what's my job?
I'm going to choose S and beta
to keep the eigenvalues of R.
So let's give the
eigenvalues of R a name.
So R-- let's say R has
eigenvalues e1, that
depends on the lambda and
the S and the beta and e2.
So those are the
eigenvalues of R--
just giving a letter to them.
So what's our job?
We want to choose S and beta
to make those eigenvalues as
small as possible.
Right?
Small eigenvalues-- if R has
small eigenvalues, its powers--
every step multiplies by
R. So the convergence rate
with momentum is--
depends on the powers
of R getting small fast.
It depends on the
eigenvalues being small.
We want to minimize
the largest eigenvalue.
So I'll say the
maximum of e1 and e2--
that's our job.
Minimize-- we want to choose
S and beta to minimize
the largest eigenvalue.
Because if there's
one small eigenvalue,
but the other is big, then the
other one is going to kill us.
So we have to get
both eigenvalues down.
And of course, those
depend on lambda.
E1 depends on lambda.
So we have a little
algebra problem.
And this is what I
described as a miracle--
the fact that this
little algebra problem--
the eigenvalues of that
matrix, e1 and e2, which
depend on lambda in some way.
And we want to make
both e1 and e2 small--
the maximum of those-- of them.
And we have to do it for
all the eigenvalues lambda,
because we have to--
we're now thinking-- we've
been tracking each eigenvector.
So that gave us 1--
so this is for all
possible lambda.
So we have to decide, what do
I mean by all possible lambda?
And I mean all lambda that
are between some m and M.
There is a beautiful problem.
You have a 2 by 2 matrix.
You can find its eigenvalues.
They depend on lambda.
And what we-- all we know
about lambda is it's between m
and cap M. And also, they
also depend on S and beta--
the two parameters
we can choose.
And we want to choose
those parameters,
so that for all the
possible eigenvalues,
the larger of the
two eigenvalues
will be as small as possible.
That's-- it's a
little bit of algebra,
but do you see that
that's the tricky--
that-- I shouldn't say
tricky, because it comes out--
this is the one that is a
miracle in the simplicity
of the solution.
OK.
And I'm going to--
in fact, maybe I'll move over
here to write the answer.
OK.
And I just want to
say that miracles
don't happen so often in math.
There is-- all of mathematics--
the whole point of math
is to explain miracles.
So there is something
to explain here,
and I don't have my
finger on it yet.
Because-- anyway, it happens.
So let me tell you what the
right S, and the right beta,
and the resulting
minimum eigenvalue are.
So again, they depend
on little m and big M.
That's a very nice
feature, which we expect.
And they depend on the ratio.
OK.
So that ratio-- all right.
Let's see it.
OK.
So the best S--
the S optimal has the formula 2
over square root of lambda max.
That's the square root of M
and the squared of m squared.
Amazing OK.
And beta optimal turns out
to be the square root of M
minus the square of little
m, over the square root of M
plus the square root of
little m, all squared.
And of course, we know
what these numbers are--
1 and beta, in
our model problem.
That's where I'm going to
get this square root of--
this is 1 minus the
square root-- oh sorry, b.
This is 1 minus the
square root of b.
In fact, for our example--
well, let me just write
what they would be.
2 over 1 plus square
root of b squared,
and 1 minus square root
of b over 1 plus square--
you see where this is--
1 minus square root of b is
beginning to appear in that.
It appears in this
solution to this problem.
And then I have to
tell you what the--
how small do these
optimal choices
make the eigenvalues
of R, right?
This is what we're really
paying attention to, because
if the eigenvalues--
that matrix tells us what
happens at every step.
And its eigenvalues have to be
small to get fast convergence.
So how small are they?
Well they involve this--
yeah.
So it's the number
that I've seen.
So in this case, the e's--
the eigenvalues of R--
that's the iterating matrix--
are below-- now you're going
to see the 1 minus square root
of b over 1 plus
square root of b--
I think, maybe, squared.
Let me just see.
Yeah.
It happens to come
out that number again.
So that's the conclusion.
That with the right
choice of S and beta,
by adding this look back
term-- look back one step--
you get this improvement.
And it happens, and you see
it in practice, of course.
You'll see it exactly.
And so you do the
job to use momentum.
Now I'm going to mention
what the Nesterov--
Nesterov had a slightly
different way to do it,
and I'll tell you what that is.
But it's the same idea--
get a second thing.
So let's see if I can find that.
Yeah, Nesterov.
OK.
Here we go.
So let me bring
Nesterov's name down.
So that's basically what I
wanted to say about number 1.
And when you see
Nesterov, you'll
see that it's a similar idea
of involving the previous time
value.
OK.
There are very popular
methods in use now
for machine learning
that involve--
by a simple formula--
all the previous
values, by sort of a--
just by an addition
of a bunch of terms.
So it's really-- so it
goes under the names
adagrad, or others.
Those of you who already
know about machine learning
will know what I'm
speaking about.
And I'll say more about those.
Yeah.
But it doesn't involve
a separate coefficient
for each previous
value, or that would
be a momentous amount of work.
So now I just want to tell
you what Nesterov is, and then
we're good.
OK.
Nesterov's idea.
Let me bring that down.
Shoot this up.
Bring down Nesterov.
Because he had an idea that
you might not have thought of.
Somehow the momentum
idea was pretty natural--
to use that previous value.
And actually, I
would like to know
what happens if you use two
previous values, or three
previous values.
Can you then get improvements
on this convergence rate
by going back two
steps or three steps?
If I'd use the analogy
with ordinary differential
equations, maybe you know.
So there are backward
difference formulas.
Do you know about those for--
those would be in
MATLAB software,
and all other software.
Backward differences--
so maybe you
go back two steps or four steps.
If you're doing
planetary calculations,
if you're an astronomer, you go
back maybe seven or eight steps
to get super high accuracy.
So that doesn't seem
to have happened yet,
but it's should happen here--
to go back more.
But Nesterov has this
different way to go back.
So his formula is XK
plus 1-- the new X--
is YK-- so he's introducing
something a little different--
minus S gradient f at YK.
I'm a little surprised
about that YK,
but this is the point, here--
that the gradient
is being evaluated
at some different point.
And then he has to give a
formula for that to track those
Y's.
So the Y's are like
the X's, but they
are shifted a little bit by some
term-- and beta would be fine.
Oh no.
Yeah-- beta-- have
we got Nesterov here?
Yes.
Nesterov has a factor gamma in.
Yeah.
So all right.
Let me try to get this right.
OK.
All right.
On a previous line, I've written
the whole Nesterov thing.
Here, let's see a
Nesterov completely.
And then it'll break--
then this is the step that
breaks it into two first order.
But you'll see the
main formula here.
XK plus 1 is XK.
And then a beta times
XK minus XK minus 1.
So that's a momentum term.
And then a typical gradient.
But now here is
Nesterov speaking up.
Nesterov evaluates the gradient
not at XK, not at XK minus 1.
But it his own, Nesterov point.
So this is Nesterov's
favorite point.
Gamma XK minus XK minus 1.
Some point, part
way along that step.
So this point-- because gamma is
going to be some non-integer--
this evaluation point
for the gradient of f
is a little
unexpected and weird,
because it's not a mesh point.
It's somewhere between.
OK.
Yeah.
And then that-- so that involves
XK plus 1, XK, and XK minus 1.
So it's a second order--
there's a second
order method here.
We're going to-- to analyze it,
we're going to go through this
same process of writing it
as two first order steps--
two first-- two single step--
two one step from K to K plus
1 coupled with one step thing.
Follow that same thing
through, and then the result
is, the same factor
appears for him.
The same factor-- this is also--
so the point is, this is
for momentum and Nesterov,
with some constant--
different by some constant.
But the key quantity is that
one and that appears in both.
So I don't propose, of
course, to repeat these steps
for Nesterov.
But you see what you could do.
You see that it involves
K minus 1, KNK plus 1.
You write it as--
you follow an eigenvector.
You write it as a coupled
system of-- that's a one step.
That has a matrix.
You find the matrix.
You find the eigenvalues
of the matrix.
You make those eigenvalues
as small as possible.
And you have optimized the
coefficients in Nesterov.
OK.
That's sort of a lot
of algebra that's
at the heart of accelerated
gradient descent.
And of course, it's
worth doing because it's
a tremendous saving in
the convergence rate.
OK.
Anybody running in the
marathon or just watching?
It's possible to run, you know.
Anyway, I'll see you after
the marathon, next Wednesday.
And Professor Boyd
will also see you.